the world you from the left in Cortez is
the us versus them it's classism the
straights versus the gays it's the
whites versus the blacks it's the me two
versus all the white males question of
the day does anybody out there really
believe that companies like Amazon or
Walmart get away with paying no taxes
let me know in which economic fallacy
myth do you most often run into in
everyday conversation let me know so let
me warn you this next segment is gonna
be a little nerdy and by little I mean
it'll make mayor Pete butt-kick look
like The Fresh Prince so I just want to
know that you understands is gonna be
dry I think it's an important segment
because one of the most pervasive
oft-repeated myths that we hear in the
current class warfare platform from the
DNC is that mega corporations like
Amazon but they pay nothing in taxes
here you it's wrong that that
corporations like Walmart can and in
Amazon can get paid they can get voiced
by the government essentially it's
essentially essentially the umbrella
term for effectively a company like
Amazon it makes ten billion dollars in
profits can walk away paying nothing in
taxes we should not have a regressive
tax system in which large profitable
corporations like Amazon pay nothing in
federal income taxes Oh sounds like
uncle Bernie drank a bucket of salt
water again the idea that corporations
there's that word corporations companies
Oh evil Citizens United that they don't
pay anything in tax its laughably untrue
and it's ironic to me that Democrats who
believe themselves after monopoly on the
ground of nuance can only make this
claim through deliberately misleading
arithmetic we commonly refer to that as
Bernie math by the way two plus two is
let me give you some context okay let's
just Amazon as a jumping-off point a
couple of things in both 2017 and 2018
separately Amazon paid about a billion
dollars in taxes okay that includes
payroll taxes income taxes local some
might say really in billion dollars
local taxes none of this to mention all
of the individual income taxes paid by
the hundreds of thousands of employees
do the jobs tree
by Amazon good thing we would think
right so what does the claim come from
it's like the wage it comes from one
number that Amazon specifically paid
nothing in federal corporate income tax
now that's true just like it's true for
General Motors but we'll get back to
that in a second this one is really easy
to figure out as to why Amazon pay
nothing exclusively in federal corporate
taxes one they get deductions for this
is they spend a lot on research and
development okay over twenty two billion
dollars and 2017 alone should Amazon be
taxed on that do you believe that it's
better for a company to not invest in
innovation would it be better if Amazon
had not invested in the two day shipping
which is soon to become one day shipping
and the new vans pioneering hassle-free
returns
forcing the entire shipping industry to
become more efficient and competitive
would that be a good thing again we
started with ten billion dollars and say
it's twenty two billion dollars in
innovation and research another reason
they get deductions for what's called
property plants and equipment
cumulatively that we spent over sixty
billion dollars by the end of 2018 would
you rather see those billions of dollars
which by the way benefit local real
estate and jobs markets hand it to the
federal government instead for context
you're something this is why this
bothers me quite a bit it's really easy
with this us-versus-them it's this
classism it's identitarian ism just in
another level of because it deals with
income all businesses in context use
these deductions guess how I know okay
when I built a new studio I obviously
deducted that as profit from the company
but guess what the new landlord makes
money off the lease when I pay someone
for a new camera needed for the show I
also write that off as an expense when I
pay someone to come in and install a
backup generator yeah that's a tax
deduction that's a bad thing the
voluntary transaction of goods and
services this is exactly why Cortes and
the far-left saw Amazon leaving New York
City is a good thing while an
overwhelming number of New Yorkers did
not this really comes whether you
believe it or not comes down to whether
you understand the numbers whether you
think it's right or not comes down to
what do you think benefits the
working-class more 25,000 jobs with an
average six-figure salary in New York or
all of that money going to Washington DC
to Divya but there does
aggression you have to make I can't make
it for you by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
because apparently subscriptions don't
mean anything on YouTube the only way to
support this show is a lot of credit I
come / my club and subscribe on iTunes
another thing that Amazon just does they
said abductions because they increased
pay for employees through stock
compensation and a big one they can
carry forward some of the losses from
the years prior when they were you they
were losing and losing billions of
dollars instead of making anything this
is something people don't understand
again you're investing 22 billion here
60 billion dollars there you can carry
forward some of those losses when you
finally become profitable all businesses
do this and they should from the local
restaurant owner to the car dealership I
can tell you I've had years after I've
paid workers I could I would literally
have to dip into savings just to invest
in inventory or website development for
the next year and you know what I'm
lucky because many businesses actually
have to borrow money to invest in next
quarter earnings let alone the next year
often inventory that's a huge bar
somebody's have to borrow to pay taxes
my father-in-law how to do that now how
did I avoid it by paying myself zero for
years so we were pretty lucky that I
didn't put any debt in the company now
if businesses couldn't do that if they
couldn't carry forward any losses no one
would invest no one would take the risk
to create a business consider this 80
percent of restaurants since we remove
it from topic corporations let's just go
to restaurants they do the same thing
they fail within the first five years
80% of restaurants knowing that a
business owner a restaurateur who Bernie
by the tip his wakes death exactly 18
percent he has an app so knowing that 80
percent fail a business is going to have
to have the confidence that they won't
be punished for employing dozens servers
chefs Busboys paying for least food
purchases all of this could cost them
and likely will cost them far more than
the restaurant makes for the first two
or three years this business owner takes
the risk in the hope set by year four or
five he can make a hefty profit why
would he take that risk if at the end of
the rainbow is Bernie was a pot of you
bet
I don't understand it all of this adds
up when we use Amazon they've invested
more than a hundred and sixty billion
dollars in the US alone since 2011
statistically significant I would say a
good thing and the beta switch here is
that the Democrats are you heard what
she said we can like cuz this is what
Nina Pinta Santa Maria Congress summons
sounds like the Democrats often conflate
tax deductions or incentives with tax
dollars they do this a lot like what
paying for the oil industry we're paying
Amazon no direct taxpayer dollars were
given to Amazon period Amazon instead
they created hundreds of thousands of
jobs and employed taxpaying citizens
which brings me back to an earlier point
there's another massive company that
paid Neff nothing in federal taxes last
year ok contra but what it is pause go
through the rewind machine General
Motors is the answer everybody who is
what is General Motors why don't we hear
them [ __ ] about that could it be that
the major difference here is that
General Motors was actually part of an
over eighty billion dollar federal auto
bailout this is what's important I'm not
that I've talked about this before I'm
not the party of big business or small
business I'm the party of good business
if you're running it honestly and you're
not taking my money to run your business
if there's no ill-gotten gain what the
hell do I care if you're a billionaire a
millionaire or a hundred thousand ere we
shouldn't care
just like we shouldn't care someone who
runs the business happens to be black
white asian it shouldn't matter to us as
long as they're playing by the rules but
when it comes to General Motors it's not
good business in other words you the
taxpayer unlike Amazon who does not work
for GM likely does not drive a crappy GM
car probably but you probably don't even
live in the same state as a GM plant you
were directly paying for their union
screw-ups and they still can't get their
balance sheets right so again this all
comes down to your worldview we can list
the facts we can and my question to you
would be this if you think they need to
be paying more in taxes if the two
billion dollars isn't enough they're
gonna be paying more in corporate to
what should the tax system look like
what system would be better than the one
that we have now that encourages people
to employ hundreds of thousands of
people the world you from the
than Cortez is the us versus them it's
classism it's the wealthy versus the
poor they do the same thing it's the the
straights versus the gays it's the
whites versus the blacks it's the me2
versus all the white males it's the the
the the the sis versus LGBTQA a IP and
whatever Slade is writing about that day
and they say we're trying to divide and
conquer is your worldview us versus them
and getting what you want which is your
fair share the fair share is what you've
earned period or do you believe in sound
business do you believe in the reward of
risk do you believe that individuals
have the right to spend their own money
that's really what this comes down to
the belief that Washington DC should
take this money despite already getting
billions of dollars and they know how to
better spend it than you my economic
world do it let's call it reductive
let's call it simplistic and I'd like to
know your thoughts on this I tend to
believe that individuals if given the
freedom and the opportunity to do so
they do things relatively well not all
but most I tend to believe that
government if centralized and given
enough power tends to do things poorly
hey there if you like this video this is
the part where I would usually tell you
to subscribe but I can't do it anymore
I'm gonna tell you to subscribe and then
YouTube is going to decide that we can't
reach you even though you subscribe to
this channel and then I'll say hit the
notification bell and then the
notification Bell won't even be there
anymore I don't know what to say more
than likely you'll find my face in a
milk carton but do what you can to stop
it it's just it's just it probably won't
do much